freedom
they'll be Pearson
at first I was quite skeptical about the
EU because Estonia was in one union for
a long time and just stepped right to be
into the other but now I realized that
it's actually been very good thing first
Estonia has been a member of the
European Union since 2004 it has more
than 1,500 offshore islands our pilot
Carla Loomis touches down with us on the
grass landing strip on the island of
rügen
our plane has been eagerly awaited
Estonia's smallest community numbering
just 60 inhabitants is completely
dependent on supplies being flown in and
here on this remotest of islands Karl
raves about how EU membership has opened
his country to the world the world is
open for us for for younger people like
me so you can work outside in the
European Union you have you can travel
you can meet other people you can live
in other countries so it's it's it's
like open society you can you can you
can have like open mind
we were in Estonia more than 10 years
ago to ask people what they expected
from accession to the European Union now
we're back and we want to know how
things have gone in Estonia since then
our trip will take us from ruku to the
island of sorry ma
where we'll meet a fisherman's family
then we'll go on to the capital Tallinn
where we'll talk to a successful
businessman in Narva on Estonia's
eastern border we'll find out how the
integration of the Russian minority is
progressing in the university town of
Tartu we'll visit a young estonian woman
and we'll end our journey on the island
of moon
this is how we remembered sorry ma
estonia's largest island thinly
populated like the entire country with
just 1.3 million people when we first
got to know fishermen urease week on the
island in 1999 coastal fishing was
scarcely worth the effort the
forthcoming EU accession gave him cause
to hope these days his catch is still
small EU membership hasn't helped in
that respect overfishing in the Baltic
Sea has left simple fishermen without a
chance so when we meet Yuri again he
tells us he's given it up as a trade you
know what I mean it's y'all I think on
none of us it's easy to see that that
still upsets him he tells us wistfully
that he'd been a professional fisherman
all his life now Yuri lives alone on his
farm he tells us he didn't really have
much luck with his wife his eldest
daughter mariana takes care of him his
two other daughters have gone abroad
Estonia is experiencing an exodus of its
young people at 62 Yuri has taken early
retirement like many older Estonians he
has a pension that barely covers his
living costs oh you know happy having a
great quarter he assures us he's
optimistic in a little he says that
things could be better but in typical
Estonian fashion he adds that you just
have to be contented with your loss then
he'll have everything below me back in
1999 Yuri and his wife had a small farm
together at the time Marit was proud of
her purebred sheep
now the animals are gone and so is she
we traced down Merritt's ouack in a
nearby village with EU funding she's
opened her own shop selling Estonian
handicrafts as a memento of our last
visit she's kept a newspaper article
from a time when she still had high
hopes
Marit tells us she's lost two jobs in
the past few years and that she'd never
imagined she'd ever be self-employed
great gun laws new Tania gilles de Rosas
she keeps up her courage by telling
herself you must be negative
entrepreneurial and believe in yourself
and not complain Jellico commissar Vanya
it's seesaw boil till Easter sit down
being self-employed is now her only
option because jobs like those in this
factory making fishing nets are few and
far between on the island
although Estonia is no longer a low-wage
country it's still an attractive
location for foreign investors
especially Scandinavian businesses such
as this Danish fishing equipment
manufacturer
you
tahleen the capital is the economic
heart of the country we recognize tour
must answer immediately a businessman
for whom the past few years have been
quite tumultuous as he tells us of 5000
fearless fighters he says the years from
2004 to 2008 were economically fantastic
in Estonia but that know many things
have changed now the unemployment rate
is very high he says and that's
especially hard for people with families
and children to support
Estonia was once considered a shining
example of radical free enterprise now
during the global financial crisis the
government is resolutely economizing and
cutting the budget and pensions to
fulfil the criteria for the euro we
accompanied our businessman friend to an
appointment in the old city center where
we notice at second glance the many
surveillance cameras medieval buildings
with modern touches and laptops are
everywhere in technology mad Estonia a
law even guarantees the right to free
internet access Thomas TomSka is well
lift up and stays networked today he's
meeting a German hotelier to discuss an
upcoming event to see dear Vita the
snick effect oh you know well D haben
get off since we last saw him thomas has
started up his own business organizing
conferences
back in 1999 at the relatively young age
of 32 he was the manager of a seatbelt
factory he was one of the new generation
of businesspeople in Estonia the once
reserved manager is now a self-confident
entrepreneur he takes us to talons
business district
he tells us he you accession has given
the country a boost and we can see that
clearly
Shabba Fonda
he says he's profited from the EU
because he took advantage of the strong
boost it gave to economic growth
well not really here because Sultana
have a hot after the profit yet
Helia take on the snap there his
conference on wage development also
focuses on the global financial crisis
Tomas hamsa remains optimistic but he
thinks his fellow Estonians ought to be
more committed to their country the
Democratic support he says the basic
democratic process is in place but that
citizens action groups haven't
progressed far inaudible
he thinks Estonians should play a more
active role than they do now badly I
doesn't
Thomas takes us to the new statue on
Freedom Square it commemorates the
country's struggle for independence in
1918 which the Estonians won but in 1940
first the Soviets occupied the country
and then the Third Reich in 1944 the
Soviet Union annexed Estonia and held it
until 1991 victim Gavin Caen of high
Heights
Thomas Hamza tells us his stone wounds
have lived with the dream of Liberty and
believed in it
since the Second World War he thinks
that for slightly older people it's
really a sacred concept I know I'm
heilige sports before we drive on he
says we absolutely must take a look at
the new art museum the Kumu a
surprisingly large building for such a
small country
the way it presents a wide array of
Estonian artists seems to us to be a
sign of the growing national
self-confidence here
some visitors however also come to see
artworks typical of the Soviet era
our journey continues north eastwards we
arrived in Estonia's problem region a
landscape dotted with dilapidated
industrial plants when we visited
earlier
environmenta lucien was rife back then
yellow sulphur dust covered the
countryside
the sulfur is no longer visible now the
EU requires filters nonetheless with oil
shale still being extracted here the air
and soil remain very polluted estonia's
primary source of energy is still the
country's largest environmental problem
we've been warned about the long lines
of trucks outside Narva waiting to be
processed by Russian customs drivers
complain about Russian harassment
relations with Estonia's giant neighbor
of frosty in 2007 there was even unrest
when a Soviet Memorial was moved in
tallying the eastern border of Estonia
is now an external border of the EU it's
closely policed
to fortresses face each other on the
Estonian Russian border
more than 90% of the population of the
industrial city of Narva is a foreign
descent the Soviet Union once settled
russian-speaking workers here now many
of them are unemployed what strikes us
is that the new signs on house corners
now there is stone Ian and North Russian
names the government is trying to
establish the Estonian language here as
well we drive to Navas powerplant where
oil shale is used to generate
electricity here we meet Ilya cooties a
Russian worker who unloads freight
wagons as they arrive
most upright you do is evolution you
know
on our earlier visit the working
language was Russian and aleeah's job
was the same as it is now back then he
was very optimistic about the country's
pending EU accession he expected
Russians here to be able to get Estonian
citizenship and travel abroad with EU
passports or open their own businesses
business my mother look sir
things have developed differently he now
says the most important change for him
was his marriage and not Estonia's EU
accession Narva is still predominantly
russian-speaking
the government's language and
integration program scarcely reached the
older generation integrating them into
society remains difficult many here see
themselves as losers and are angry that
since EU accession they have to pay for
a visa to go to Russia
Elia too is disappointed with the EU and
looks to his private life for happiness
little is left of the hope he placed in
the European Union although he has an
Estonian passport like many ethnic
Russians in Estonia
he thinks the integration policies have
failed as have attempts at rapprochement
yeah toaster ludis but rather said the
hostess
Celia tells us he doesn't think Russians
here are particularly glad to have you
passports
why do you conceal it he says many of
them would trade their EU citizenship
for a Russian passport en nog you Hotel
Suzette's oski passport uh you are this
King I'll better bruh from the Northeast
we travel on to the south
every day Celia head misty rides her new
motorbike several kilometers from the
city of Tartu to her place of work
the company she works for makes garden
sheds from timber one of Estonia's
principal raw materials wood products
are among the country's main exports
Celia works in marketing and sales she's
taking pictures for the new catalogue
my name leave you in the lab she tells
us her life has changed a great deal
during the past 10 years
she finished University and then got
this good job which she says offers her
many opportunities for advancement
escaping to give you gave him he evaded
20 beacon celia showed this same
eagerness for education and training the
first time we met her back then she was
a student getting ready for European
Union accession at the University of
Tartu
Celia has remained true to her
university town just as it's always been
tarter is still the country's main
educational center and well-educated
young citizens are estonia's most
valuable asset
senior proudly shows us her new
apartment she seems to have done well in
the intervening years
she bought the apartment together with
her boyfriend who's on a business trip
at present Celia has profited from her
language skills lately she's added
French to the list and soon she tells us
she might study Arabic young Estonians
are probably more committed to the EU
because it enhances their opportunities
on her last holiday she went to
Switzerland she says she could also
imagine working there sometime before we
leave she tells us about her own plans
for the future in momentum in his sham
crime Levinson - Frieden and she says
she's very satisfied with her life at
present she and her boyfriend have also
been thinking about starting a family
knocking dad so hardened that would be
lovely for Celia and would for Estonia
the small Republic has one of Europe's
lowest birth rates
we travel onwards the ferry takes us to
the island of moo-hoo the last leg of
our journey
moo-hoo is a byword for unspoiled nature
in Estonia with bears wolves Lynx deer
and all sorts of Wildlife
in a secluded spot we come upon pedestal
murmur the 1300 manor houses in Estonia
used to belong to German aristocrats who
ruled the country for more than 700
years better stay was renovated with the
aid of EU subsidies and it's now a
luxury hotel with guests from around the
world
a bit further on the island we run into
tour guide Anna Corey Paolo whom we got
to know on our last visit she's meeting
up with Martin Kiva saw an old
schoolmate - what - mr. both our true
nature lovers and keep a close watch on
the environment in their country they
had high hopes for EU accession I think
that very many places in nature are much
better now we have much less pollution
thanks to EU I have seen it during my
last 10 years traveling around the stone
iya that rivers which were full of
pollution ten years ago now Salomon and
toad has returned in 1999 Anna koreff
aloo was working as a guide in Lima
National Park in northern Estonia even
then she was convinced the country's
pristine nature would attract tourists
when this tonyia will be a member of EU
than those countries who haven't this
all left they can come here and enjoy
maybe this is that part
what Estonia can give to EU unspoiled
nature and here they are the hoped-for
tourists these fins are on Martin's
horses exploring old cult sites martin
induct them into the mystical world of
pre-christian customs
but to us it has a mysterious quality of
alcoholic in front of a sacred boulder
green is offered to the gods and the
lightest on Omar like at the on guard
as I always say I am a free person in a
free country
I like independence and freedom very
much - Martin Kiva saw the horses of MU
who symbolize Estonians identity and
culture and their age-old love of
freedom
boy Steven main my real vertical our
before we leave Martin shows us his
project for the future on his property a
center dedicated to pre-christian
civilizations built with EU aid and he
takes leave of us with his personal
views on Estonia and the European Union
and yeah as he puts it people can be
happy with or without the EU but they
have a better chance of succeeding in
the EU that Foulke
come in a mayor hardened by the end of
our trip we've seen that European Union
membership has vastly increased the
opportunities available in Estonia and
we have the impression that many
Estonians have made use of them
you
you
you